but once you get out he kind of need a
fight look at owner he wants to go in he
doesn't like this tough not to have the
C the it's kind of hard to go in though
T oh
Faker and he puts a tower oh my God he
just won the game he just won the game
that's it they can end they can end the
game jdg the goliaths from China we're
having one of the most dominant years in
League of Legends history I seriously
doubted whether any human could stop
them from reaching the final of Worlds
this year but Faker Ain't
Human all right just before we get into
today's video we've got brand new merch
check it out you can do it when you're
at the lake or in the server by yourself
or with the bugs never let anyone tell
you it's wrong because baiton it always
feels good a zip up Hoodie made for all
those who mastered the art of baiting
check out the score eorts drop two
available now all right if you like the
look of any of that check out the link
in the description below so T1 and Faker
have a date with WBO at the world's 2023
final Faker is now one series away from
taking home his fourth world's title 10
years after his first seven years after
his most recent but let's talk about the
jdg game first before we get too carried
away the odds were against T1 I talked
about this extensively last week the
safer bet was probably on jdg were the
team that had won everything they could
so far this year they were the ones who
had only lost five Series in 2023 they
were the ones on track to achieve the
never been achieved before Golden Road
Beaker and T1 were pretty Immaculate all
around and everyone on the team seemed
to have their own moment throughout the
Series game one we got to see carrier
absolutely Flex on Bard and Gushi pull
out the first gin game we've seen at
world so far and they find can going
right back in his owner in the area gig
damage coming in for the darken blade
missing on the backside trying to buy
some space with a shock wave it's clean
and in Comes The Curtain Call game three
saw owner pull off one of the sickest
engages on ra I've seen in a long time
might go for the 50/50 but it's
absolutely psycho flashes over the arrow
fer goes in it's incredibly clean jdg
with the counter punch can they get
anything back ruler untouched on the
backside Dragon Still Standing but own
will take that away too my God what an
engage from t
and in that game we had what might go on
to be an alltime iconic world's moment
jdg had a gold Le they were besieging
T's base with Baron buff T1 were praying
for a miracle and Faker answered their
prayers with anaz from
[Music]
heaven
I love Gushi and ker fanboying there in
that clip I really felt that it's kind
of like for a moment they realized that
their own mid laner was quite literally
Faker Goomer also had an absolutely
disgusting 1 V2 play in game four goes
gold out ruler looking to take over the
fight rer Still Standing standing go
firing back ruler goes down Go's just
better after that it was clear T1 wen't
going to let this series reach silver
scrapes they had their eyes on finals it
is not LPL versus lck it is T1 versus
the LPL and they like those odds as they
move to finals the legendary Korean
Caster Yun broke down on stream after
the game it was an emotional moment for
a lot of people outside of the Korean
scene so I can only imagine what a
pillar of it like Yun must have felt we
said it was going to feel like a final
it really did and the numbers reflected
that too the series peaked to over 4.3
million viewers making it the second
most watched League of Legends series of
all time that's right the only series
that attracted more viewers was last
year's finals which also featured T1 and
to be honest I wouldn't be surprised if
this year's finals breaks that record
too some people have pointed out that
WBO is actually extremely popular in the
LPL pulling in huge viewership numbers
this year a lot of these fans are likely
fans of Xiao from his RNG days crisps
fpx fans but perhaps more than anyone
fans of the Shai it's hard to understate
just how rever the Shai is in China the
2018 World Champion is a beloved
celebrity with millions of followers so
yeah all things considered I think this
upcoming Final has a real chance of
breaking the alltime viewership record
and I know viewership numbers don't
always tell the full story about an
Esports Health but breaking viewership
records certainly doesn't hurt T1 did
lose the coin toss for game one side
selection this week with WBO choosing
blue side but Faker didn't really look
phased at all in fact he almost look
quietly amused by the whole thing and to
be fair T1 had redside in all three of
their games in their stomp over LG in
quarters so they're probably not
sweating it too much so the question on
everyone's mind now is will this finals
be close maybe but a lot of people feel
like we've already seen the real final
I'm going to be honest and I don't want
to like deflate the World Finals cuz I
think it's still hype and I really hope
that we see an insane best of five but
I'm going to I'm going to deflate it I
think T1 clear in every role and their
draft is infinitely easier and better
like and I don't think that's a bold
statement this is an impossible puzzle
congratulations team one there's no way
waybo can come back yeah and if I jinx
it great true I'll shave my head at WBO
win Worlds there's definitely a really
strong belief now that T1 will be able
to do it this time that Faker and
friends will be able to get over that
line in pickham over 90% of fans are
backing T1 to win I'm not even sure the
last time I saw the league community so
United with a prediction last series a
lot of people were saying their hearts
were going with T1 but their heads said
jdg I don't think that's the case
anymore with this upcoming series even
if you're not a T1 fan it's hard to
argue they're not the favorites here
they look like they've solved the meta
particularly with fully ranged bot lanes
that have come about mid tournament but
there's definitely a lot of creeping
down in everyone's minds too remember
this exact same T1 roster was in the
same situation last year they were
expected to beat the underdogs in DRX
and they didn't that will likely be on
the minds of these T1 players and their
fans and for Faker he'll probably
remember the 2017 finals he missed out
on too in the first four years of
faker's professional career he won
worlds three times think about that in
the year since he's attended worlds five
times got to the finals twice but never
won that trophy again I don't care if
you're literally Faker you're going to
feel that mounting pressure I'm sure
he's wondered at times why these world's
titles came so easily to him in the
beginning of his career but have eluded
him ever since Faker has to carry the
pressure of being the League of Legends
goat but without any recent world's
title to point to he's now one series
away from getting that added to all that
pressure this may be the last time we
see this T1 roster play together if they
don't win this final they've been
together for two years they've won
domestic titles they've broken records
they've had massive lows and
unbelievable Highs but will they run it
back for another year if they let yet
another world's trophy slip through
their fingers a lot of people suspect no
that could be a lot of pressure for T1
going into this series a lot of pressure
that wo simply doesn't have sure they'll
be feeling the nerves of going into the
biggest League of Legends series of the
year but nobody expected them to get
this far geneng jdg LNG even T1 after a
certain point these were the teams that
people were expecting to see in the
final as respectable as they've been
webo was not one of them and that
Underdog mentality can go a long way it
can ease off some of that pressure and
turn the whole F into a sort of David
and Goliath situation but really
analyzing history can only get you so
far trying to guess the psychological
state of T1 and Faker has its limit what
really matters is how these teams come
together on the day Faker is now three
to five wins away from lifting the
Summoner cup that's it that would have
sounded absolutely absurd a few months
ago when T1 were a middle of the pack
lck team trying to find their feet with
an injured Faker on the bench but that's
exactly where we are there's nothing
more to say say than this if T1 wins
this series Faker will Ascend beyond God
status in League of Legends it's that
simple the few Edge Lords out there that
have been trying to argue that Faker
isn't the Undisputed goat will have
nothing left to say this would be a man
that had won his first Worlds at 17
years old he'd won three by the time he
was 20 for the next seven years he
watched his teammates come and go as T1
failed to reach those lofty Heights
again but he never gave up he never lost
hope he never stopped grinding he never
let the setbacks Define him including an
absolutely heartbreaking world's final
last year where he was just a single
game away from Redemption and now his
reward for all of this perseverance is
right there for the taking if you wanted
to pull off what he's done this year to
get to this point and then go and win
the whole thing you literally have to be
Faker so it's a good job he literally
is yeah I'd like to see if anyone in the
comments can recognize any of the items
on the shelves they they're out of focus
but there's a few uh Esports gaming
items up there some of them I have no
idea what they are either so help me out
guys
please